هجوم روسي لم تشهد له العاصمه الاوكرانيه
مثيرا منذ الربيع وفق الاداره العسكريه
لمقاطعه كييف بدا من مسيرات من اتجاهات
مختلفه وتبعه هجوم بالصواريخ ولم تسلم
مناطق وسط وجنوب البلاد من هجمات ممثله
وفق قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
ليست كييف وحدها من عاشت التصعيد فبدورها
تعرضت مقاطعات عده غربيه روسيا لهجوم واسع
بمسيره اوكرانيه كان ابرزها في بيسكوف حيث
استهدف مطار المدينه واسفر عن تضرر اربع
طائرات عسكريه
ما حدث فتحتك هناك بشان مصدر المسيرات
فبيسكوب تقع شمال غربي روسيا على حدود
استونيا ولاتفيا وعلى بعد نحو 800 كم من
اوكرانيا المتحدث باسم المخابرات
الاوكرانيه اكد ان الهجوم تم من خلال
مجموعات محليه تعمل على الاراضي الروسيه
وفيما يمكن اعتباره تلميحا قالت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه انه لم يكن من
الممكن قطع الطائره المسيره الاوكرانيه
مثل هذه المسافه دون معلومات من الاقمار
الاصطناعيه الغربيه تبدو الاشارات لجيران
روسيا الاعضاء في النيتو ما دفع وزيره
الدفاع لوصف الادعاءات بعلاقه بلادها
باحدث بالامر السخيف للغايه حرب المسيرات
لم تقتصر على بسكوت فحكم اوريول اعلن
اسقاط مسيرتين اوكرانيتين فوق المقاطعه
كما اكدت سلطات مقاطعات
اوكرانيه عده
زخم الاستخدام الواسع للمسيرات من قبل
اوكرانيا رات هوموسكو دليلا على وصولها
الى طريق مسدود حسب تعبيرها
البحر الاسود فبدوره مسرح نزال اخر حاكم
مدينه
في شبه جزيره القرم اعلن عن تصدي الدفاعات
الجويه لهجوم اوكراني بالمسيرات وبالمقابل
اعلنت دفاع روسيه تدمير الطائراتها اربعه
قوارب سريعه في حوض البحر الاسود على
متنها نحو 50 عنصرا من القوات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه في حين اعلنت القوات البحريه
الاوكرانيه رصد اربعه عشره سفينه وصفتها
بالمعاديه وبعضها تحمل صواريخ كروز في
البحر الاسود وبحر ازوف والبحر المتوسط
على الارض وتحديدا فيزا الجنوبيه البلاد
يتواصل هجوم القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
مدينه
وفق قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه وذلك بعد
اعلان استعاده السيطره على بلده روبوتين
في المقاطعه لكن الدفاع الروسيه تقول انها
تصد الهجمات هناك وفي دنياتك وتواصل
عملياتها في الجبهه الشرقيه باتجاه
الايمان وبخموت رئيس اركان الجيش
الاوكراني بطل لقطات للحظه التدمير دبابه
روسيه في منطقه وصفها بالاكثر سخونه
اوكرانيه وتلك حرب اخرى في الاعلام لتاكيد
التقدم على الجبه